Hai, de wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ‘settle,’
sore kara, ‘finish, relieve,’ to itta
imi ga arimasu.
De, component wo chotto mite ikimashō.
Kore kara desu ne, kono radical wo mitara,
itsumo ‘water.’
Kono radical wa Nihongo de ‘sanzui’ to
iimasu.
So this radical always stands for water.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, kore wa ‘bun.’
So ‘letter.’
And this part looks like a ladder.
So imagine a story where near the water, someone
is climbing up the ladder with a letter, with
his hand to finish or settle a battle.
To iu no de, ma, ‘finish.’
Sore kara ‘settle,’ no imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata desu keredo mo, on reading.
Kore wa ‘zai.’ ‘kēzai,’ ‘economics.’
Sore kara, ‘kyūsai,’ kore wa ‘to rescue’
to iu imi desu.
Kun reading desu keredo mo, kun reading wa
‘su’ to iimasu.
De, intransitive verb de ‘nani nani ga sumu,’
‘something is done or get done.’
Tatoeba, ‘shiken ga sunda,’ ‘the exam
was done.’
Sore kara, intransative verb.
Kono toki ni wa, ‘nani nani wo sumaseru.’
Tatoeba, ‘hayaku shukudai wo sumasete kudasai,’
‘finish your homework as early as possible.’
Konna imi ga arimasu.
Hai, de wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji, imi wa ‘article’ to ka ‘goods’
no imi ga arimasu.
Mō, kono component daijōbu desu yo ne. ‘kuchi,’
‘mouth.’
So, a person with three mouths.
A salesman talks a lot in order to sell goods.
To iu no de, ma, ‘goods’ to iu imi desu
kedo.
Yomikata nan desu keredo mo, on reading.
Kore wa ‘hin’ to iimasu.
Tatoeba, ‘shokuhin,’ kore wa ‘taberu
goods’ so goods to eat, ma, foods desu yo
ne.
Sore kara, ‘shōhin,’ kore wa ‘merchandise.’
Taoteba, ‘kono mise wa donna shōhin wo
utteimasuka?’
Sore kara, ‘sēhin,’ ‘manufactured goods.’
‘kono kaisha wa donna sēhin wo tsukutteimasuka?’
Sore kara, kono combination, kore wa ‘sakuhin,’
‘work,’ nan desu keredo mo, art ni kankeishita
work.
So, work related to art.
Tatoeba, music.
Sore kara, painting.
Sore kara, novels to ka, literature.
Sō itta work desu.
Tatoeba, ‘kono shōsetsu wa, Natsume Sōseki
no sakuhin desu,’ ‘the work by Sōseki
Natsume,’ to iu imi desu.
Sore kara, ‘hinshitsu.’
Kore wa goods no quality.
Tatoeba, ‘kono shōhin wa, hin shitsu ga
ii.’ ‘good quality’ to iu imi desu.
Sore kara ‘jōhin’ to iu, kore ‘na adjective’
nan desu keredo mo, ‘elegant’ to iu imi
ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, ‘kanojo wa jōhin na hito da.’
Konna tsukaikata wo shimasu.
Sore kara kun reading de wa ‘shina.’
Amari tsukaimasen keredo mo.
Tatoeba, ‘shina’ kore ‘goods.’
Sore kara ‘shinamono’ kore de ‘goods,’
dochira mo onaji imi desu.
Hai, de wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ‘insect,
bug’ to iu imi ga arimasu.
Chotto component wo mitemimashō.
Kono part, sō desu ne, you can imagine a
magnifying glass, and this part you can imagine
an insect.
So together it’s more like someone is investigating
or looking into the insect with a magnifying
glass, to iu imi nan desu ga.
Yomikata desu ga, on reading de ‘chū’
to iu imi ga arimasu.
‘konchū,’ kore wa, kore de, ma, ‘insect’
Sore kara, kun reading desu keredo mo, ‘mushi.’
Kore mo ‘insect’ no imi desu.
Sore kara kore ‘mushiba,’ omoshiroi desu
ne.
Kono kanji wa ‘ha,’ ‘teeth,’ no imi
ga arimasu.
So there is an insect in your teeth, so this
is ‘cavity.’
Sore kara ‘yowamushi.’
‘yowai,’ kore wa ‘weak’ desu yo ne.
‘yowamushi’ to iu no de ‘coward.’
Sore kara ‘nakimushi.’
Kore wa ‘naku’ to iu kanji, ‘to cry,’
so ‘crybaby’ desu.
Kono lesson de desu ne, minna wa kono Tezuka
Osamu to iu Nihon de ichiban yūmē na mangaka
wo benkyōshimasu.
Tezuka Osamu wa Astroboy to ka kō itta manga
wo kaiteiru hito desu.
De, kono hito no namae no koko ni ichiban
saigo, kono kanji ga kono insect to iu kanji
desu.
Hai, de wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji, imi wa ‘round.’
Sore kara desu ne, toki doki desu kedo, this
kanji can be used as a suffix for names of
ships or people desu.
De, ma, toku ni story wa nain desu keredo
mo, there’s no story associated with this
character, but you see this ‘kyu,’ desu
yo ne, kanji no ‘kyu.’
Sore kara dot desu kedo.
Kono dot wa koko ni oite kudasai.
Yomikata desu ga, kun reading de ‘maru’
to iu no ga arimasu.
Tatoeba ‘marui,’ ‘round.’
Sore kara, ‘hinomaru,’ kore wa ‘Nihon
no flag’ to iu imi desu.
‘hinomaru.’
So you can see the round of the sun in the
Japanese flag.
Hinomaru.
Yoku ‘hinomaru no hata’ to iimasu.
Sore kara, ‘marugao.’
Kore wa marui kao, ‘round face.’
Sore kara desu ne, kono rē, ‘Nihon maru’
desu kedo, kore wa, this is the one of the
kind of the name for Nihonmaru, one ship.
Nihonmaru.
So this is a case where this kanji can be
used as a suffix for the name of a ship.
Nihonmaru.
Sore kara, kore mo amari tsukawarenain desu
keredo mo, kun reading de ‘gan’ to iu
no ga arimasu.
Kore ‘ichigan,’ kore ‘one lump’ to
iu tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Hai.
De wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji, imi wa ‘life’ no imi ga arimasu.
De, chotto kono component wo mite kudasai.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, so this character
actually itself means ‘order’ no imi ga
arimasu.
De, mō hitotsu; rēwa, kore wa ima no, this
is rēwa, this is the current era of Japan.
Rēwa nan nen to iu.
And nisen nijyūichi nen wa rēwa san nen
desu.
So rēwa actually literally means ‘the order
of peace’ to iu imi desu.
Sore kara, kono part, kono part wa, ii desu
ne, mō, ‘kuchi,’ ‘mouth,’ no imi
desu.
So a mouth issuing an order, it’s a matter
of life and death, to iu no de, ma, kore,
zenbu de ‘life’ to iu imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata desu keredo mo, kun reading de ‘inochi.’
Tatoeba, ‘kimi no inochi wo morau!’ literally
‘I will receive the life, your life,’
nan desu keredo mo, ma, imi toshite wa ‘omae
wo korosu zo,’ ‘I will kill you,’ to
iu yō na imi desu ga.
Sore kara, ‘kare no inochi wa, amari nagakunai,’
‘his life won’t be so long.’
Ato, on reading de ‘mē’ to iu yomikata
wo shimasu.
Tatoeba, ‘sēmē,’ kore wa ‘life.’
Sore kara ‘mērē’ desu keredo mo, ‘life
order’ kore ‘order’ no imi ga arimasu.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa, desu ne, ‘war,’
‘fight, battle’ no imi ga arimasu.
Chotto component wo mite ikimashō.
Kore kara kono part, kono component wo mitara,
imagine, think about spear.
Sore kara, hidarigawa no part.
Kono kanji wa, this kanji itself means ‘individual,’
or ‘single,’ to iu imi ga arimasu keredo
mo, so one individual with a spear, so he’s
probably going to go to fight or battle.
Sō iu imi ga arimasu.
Yomikata desu keredo mo, on reading, kore
ga ‘sen.’
Tatoeba, ‘sensō,’ ‘war,’ desu ne.
Particle chotto kiwotsukete kudasai.
‘Nani nani to sensō suru.’
Sore kara, ‘dai ni ji sekai taisen,’ ‘the
world war two,’ ‘dai ichi ji sekai taisen,’
‘the world, world war first’ no imi desu.
Sore kara ‘sengo, senzen’ desu yo ne.
Sensō no ato, sensō no mae.
Ato, ‘senjō.’
Kore wa ‘battlefield’ no imi desu.
Kun reading de ‘tatakau’ to iu yomikata
ga arimasu.
‘Tatakau.’
Tatoeba, ‘Ano team to tatakaimasu.’
Particle wa dochira mo ‘to’ desu. kyōtsukete
kudasai.
Hai, de wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ‘contend,
dispute, argue’ no imi ga arimasu.
Chotto component wo mite mimashō.
Story desu keredo mo, kono part.
Imagine someone’s mouth opening.
And this part, imagine that the shape of the
hand.
So someone is holding a stick and shouting
to argue or to dispute or to contend.
Sonna story wo kangaete mite kudasai.
Ato, yomikata desu keredo mo, on reading de
wa ‘sō.’
Tatoeba, ‘sensō.’
Sore kara, ‘ronsō,’ kore wa, ma, ‘argument,
argumentation’ no imi desu. ‘ron’ wa
‘riron,’ ‘ronbun,’ sono logic no imi
desu kedo.
Sore kara ‘kyōsō,’ ‘to compete,’
to iu mono ga arimasu.
Ato, kun reading de “arasou’ to iu tsukaikata
o shimasu.
Tatoeba, ‘chūgoku to arasoimasu.’
Ma, kore wa ‘to argue,’ toiuka ‘to fight
with’ no imi mo detekimasu.
Koko no particle wa ‘to’ desu kara kyōtsukete
kudasai.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ‘not yet’
to iu imi desu.
Story desu keredo mo, you can imagine a tree,
a sapling tree with small branches.
So this tree is not yet fully grown.
Dakara ‘not yet’ to iu imi desu kedo.
Yomikata nan desu ga, on reading de wa ‘mi’
to iu imi ga arimasu.
‘mirai,’ future.
Sore kara ‘mikansē,’ kore wa ‘kansē’
to iu no wa ‘to complete’ no imi desu.
So ‘not completed’ or ‘unfinished.’
Sore kara, ‘mikon.’
Kono ‘kon’ tte iu no wa, ‘kekkon,’
‘marriage’ no imi desu.
So ‘marriage not yet,’ meaning ‘not
married’ to iu tsukaikata ga arimasu.
Hai.
Jya, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa ‘deep’ no
imi ga arimasu.
Chotto component wo mitemimashō.
Kono radical.
Kono radical wo mitara, itsumo water.
Kore ‘sanzui’ to iimasu.
Water no imi wo kangaete kudasai.
Sore kara kono, kono bubun desu keredo mo,
you can associate this part with another kanji
‘ana,’ which means ‘hole.’
Sore kara, koko, kore wa mō minna shittemasu
yo ne, ‘tree.’
So you can imagine a boat tree, or I mean
the tree boat, with a hole, so that it will
sink into the water, deeply.
So kore zenbu de ‘deep’ to iu imi desu.
Yomikata desu keredo mo, kun reading de ‘fukai.’
Sore kara, on reading de ‘shin.’
Tatoeba, ‘shinya,’ kore wa ‘yoru ga
fukai.’
So, ma, ‘deep in the night,’ ma, ‘late
at night’ to iu imi desu.
Sore kara, ‘shinkai,’ kore wa ‘deep
ocean’ or ‘deep sea.’
Sore kara na adjective de ‘shinkoku na’
to iu na adjective ga arimasu.
Imi wa ‘serious’ desu.
Hai.
Jya, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu keredo mo, imi wa ‘number’
desu.
Sore kara, ‘destination,’ ‘sign,’
to iu imi ga arimasu.
Story desu keredo mo, toku ni story wa arimasen.
There’s no really nice story to this, to
describe this kanji but kono part, kore wa
‘mouth.’
Sore kara, kore mo shita no part, nan desu
keredo mo, this part looks like kanji ‘man,’
but it’s actually not.
So there’s no line here.
So be careful.
De, yomikata desu keredo mo, on reading de
‘gō.’
Tatoeba, ‘bangō,’ ‘number.’
Sore kara ‘nengō,’ ‘the name of an
era.’
Tatoeba, ‘ima no Nihon no nengō wa rēwa
desu.’
Sore kara ‘kigō,’ ‘symbol.’
‘shingō,’ ‘traffic light.’
Sore kara number plus ‘gōsha’ to iu no
de counter toshite mo tsukawaremasu.
Tatoeba, densha no sono car number, wo shime
shimasu.
‘ichigōsha,’ ‘car number one.’
‘nigōsha,’ ‘car number two.’
Konna tsukaikata mo arimasu.
Hai.
De wa, tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji, imi wa ‘sad’ to iu imi ga
arimasu.
Chotto component wo mite mimashō.
Mazu, ue no component, kono part desu keredo
mo, kono part no imi wa ‘negative,’ to
ka ‘un’ no imi ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, ‘hijō.’
Kore, kono kanji wa desu ne, ‘usual’ no
imi ga arimasu.
So hijō tte iu no wa ‘unsual.’
Demo, ‘hijō ni’ tte iu no de ‘very
much’ to iu imi mo arimasu.
Tsugi.
Kono shita no part.
Kono part wa minna yoku shitteru to omoun
desu keredo mo, ‘heart’ no imi ga arimasu.
So the heart has negative feeling, so, you
are sad, to iu imi desu.
Yomikata nan desu keredo mo, kun reading de
wa ‘kanashii.’
Sore kara on reading de wa ‘hi’ to iu
yomikata ga arimasu.
Tatoeba, ‘higeki.’
Kono ‘geki’ to iu no wa ‘play’ to
ka ‘theatre’ no imi ga arun desu keredo
mo, so ‘higeki,’ ‘tragedy’ no imi
desu.
Hai.
Tsugi no kanji desu.
Kono kanji desu kedo, imi wa ‘norm, status,
rank, standard,’ ma, kō itta imi ga arimasu.
De, hidarigawa no kono radical, kore wa daijōbu
desu yo ne, ‘tree.’
Sore kara migigawa, kono part nan desu keredo
mo, by itself actually it stands for the meaning
of ‘each.’
‘kaku’ to iu fu ni yomimasu keredo mo,
so you can imagine like each tree has its
own standard, or status, ma, sonna fu ni oboete
ii ka to omoimasu.
De, reading desu kedo, kore on reading de
‘kaku’ to iimasu.
Tatoeba, ‘sēkaku,’ kore ‘personality.’
‘taikaku,’ kore wa karada, body, so ‘body
status’ to iu no de ‘physique.’
Sore kara ‘kakaku,’ ‘price, cost.’
Ato desu ne, ‘gōkaku,’ ‘gōkaku suru,’
‘to pass entrance exam’ to iu no ni,
Tatoeba, ‘nyūgaku shiken ni gōkaku shita,’
‘I passed the entrance exam.’
Particle ‘ni,’ ‘ni’ kyōtsukete kudasai.